c'est toujours difficile de se forcer et
pour être directement honnête avec vous
que ce soit pour une prise de parole en
public ou pour un tour de qualification
lors des 24 heures du mans
l'adif la difficulté elle est la mère on
a juste un avantage en sport auto cet
avantage c'est la multitude de
paramètres que l'on a à gérer comme la
température des pneus ou la gestion du
trafic qui fait que ça ne vous laisse
pas spécialement le choix du moment pour
vous est lancé alors vous respirer un
grand coup et banzaï
vous êtes parti pour un tour à 235 km
heure de moyenne avec des pointes de
vitesse à plus de 340 km
alors je respire un grand coup et c'est
parti mais tout d'abord je voulais vous
remercier à vous tous d'être présent ici
ce soir
sachez que c'est un vrai honneur pour
moi d'être ici devant un bon kid et 1h10
bien évidemment exigences envers
soi-même pour être à la hauteur et donc
un léger sentiment de stress
bref une nouvelle fois rien de très
différent par rapport au sport auto
si je suis devant vous ce soir c'est que
je souhaite partager avec vous une
conviction
je suis convaincu que nous sommes entrés
dans une nouvelle ère que nous sommes
entrés dans une nouvelle ère où tout se
joue à rien une ère où à rien et même
parfois une accumulation de rien peut
avoir un vrai impact sur nous
ce rien j'ai aussi tendance à l'appeler
le détail pour moi aujourd'hui
le succès se joue dans le détail alors
pourquoi le succès sutil dans les
détails je vais vous montrer de photos
la première date de 2014
elle semble assez le suicide n'est pas
forcément besoin de vous expliquer la
seconde photo et date de 2015
et malheureusement pour moi cette photo
elle est tout autant exclusivité je
pense que vous avez compris à quoi ça
correspond même si vous avez compris que
la première photo est synonyme de succès
et que la seconde est synonyme d'échec
la vraie différence entre ces deux
photos n'est pas réellement dans le
résultat mais dans la manière
diarra et cette différence elle est là à
cet endroit là vous voyez la courbe de
vitesse en bleu c'est la courbe de 2014
et la courbe de la vitesse en rouge
celle de 2015 qui sont superposés et la
différence elle est vraiment à
l'intérieur de ce rectangle vert où vous
voyez que la cour de la vitesse en bleu
dont celle de 2014 et poursuit
tranquillement son chemin alors que
celle de 2015 en rouge s'arrête
brutalement dans un mur à 230 km alors
j'imagine que vous n'êtes pas forcément
familier avec ce genre de graphiques et
donc je vous aider un petit peu ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que sur ce
graphique j'ai capturé une zone d'un
seul virage vous avez dans le rectangle
jaune la ligne droite qui précède le
virage dans le rectangle vert
la zone du virage et dans le rectangle
bleu violet la ligne droite qui suit
virage alors je vais vous mettre une
petite vidéo pour vous aider à
comprendre un petit peu plus et donc à
ce moment là je suis dans le rectangle
c'est à dire que je suis dans la ligne
droite qui précède le
maintenant
je vais rentrer dans le rectangle bleu
c'est à dire que gérant dans la zone
irak je freine puis je tourne le volant
et ensuite
ressort tranquille
achetons entrer dans le rectangle bleu
violet qui est la ligne droite qui suit
virage ce qui fait que maintenant vous
avez un petit peu mieux compris à quoi
correspond ce graphique en fait la seule
chose qu'il fallait comprendre c'est que
l'axé des abscisses correspond à la
distance de parcours la voiture vous
parlez de ce petit détail qui m'a
projeté dans un mur à 230 km ce petit
détail il est à l'intérieur de ce cercle
à ce moment là en 2015 j'ai 0,03 j'ai
latéral de plus qu'en 2014 qu'est ce
qu'un rejet latéral en fait on parle de
la force g c'est à dire que lorsque on
parle d'un g c'est-à-dire qu'on supporte
la force de notre corps une fois on peut
parler de 2 g ça veut dire qu'on
supporte deux fois doctor on peut parler
de 3g en supporter trois points notre
corps et en sport automobile ça peut
aller environ jusqu'à 5g à ce moment là
en 2014
j'avais 0,78 j'ai latéral alors qu'en
j'ai eu à 0 81 g latéral soit une
différence de 0,03 et latérales et
pourtant cette différence vous êtes sûr
qu'elle est un film qu'elle est
quasiment insensible pour un humain et
pourtant elle a fait qu'en 2014
j'ai fini la course des 24 heures du
mans sur le podium alors qu'en 2015
elle c'est fini pour moi au bout de neuf
heures de course dans un mur à 230 km
à ce moment là vous rentrer aux stands
vont rentrer aux stands à pied bien
évidemment parce que vous voyez pas
repartir et vous devez expliquer à
l'ensemble de votre équipe
les raisons de cet accident raison que
je vous assure je ne connaissais pas
puissent tous pour moi 0,03 j'ai c'est
quelque chose d'un sensible et donc je
n'avais pas compris mon erreur à ce
moment là n'est pas seulement de ruiner
votre propre course mais vous venez de
ruiner la course de vo2 poétique et de
vos mécaniciens et de vos ingénieurs un
cycle de toutes les personnes qui se
sont investies dans le projet
or je vous garantis que depuis ce jour
là je ne vois plus les petits détails de
la même manière et tout pour moi ils
sont vraiment devenus des clés de succès
pour piloter ma vie à haute vitesse j'ai
quatre clips succès tu me permettent de
piloter ma vie avec vitesse la première
c'est l'exigence
la deuxième c'est la curiosité
la troisième c'est l'audace et la
quatrième c'est la diversification
premièrement j'ai envie de vous dire
soyez exigeants soyez exigeants envers
vous même car si vous l'êtes envers vous
même vous pourrez lui l'être envers les
autres je vous ai dit que depuis 2015 je
ne voyais plus les petits détails de la
même manière il y a trois semaines j'ai
un petit peu amusé l'ensemble des
speakers de stades fixe ainsi que des
intervenants des organisateurs lorsqu'on
était à un after work ou jeu carburait
au perrier citron et où je me refusais
de céder à la tentation des fameux
plateau de charges et à ce moment là
qu'il aurait expliqué qu'en sport
automobile nous nous battons contre le
poids et qui étend à trois semaines des
24 heures du mans
je voulais perdre 5 kilos pour être le
plus performant possible
alors pourquoi nous battons nous contre
le poids en sport auto et bien c'est
assez simple si vous vous devez tirer
une table qui fait 10 kg ce sera plus
simple officiel t 11 kg s'il faut
comprendre que pour une voiture de
course c'est la même chose
plus vous êtes léger plus la voiture on
fera avancer rapidement
maintenant je vais vous montrer le
résultat des qualifications des 24
heures du mans qui ont eu lieu il ya dix
jours le 14 juin 2018
vous voyez en première position la
voiture du d'exploration c'est la
voiture que j'ai la chance de piloter ce
jour là j'ai réalisé la pole position
des 24 heures du mans alors je pense que
sur cette photo vous ne voyez pas
précisément parce que c'est écrit en
petit mais sur cette deuxième photo vous
allez mieux comprendre
j'ai réalisé un tour en 3 minutes 24
secondes et 842 millièmes alors que le
pilote qui a fait le deuxième temps à
réaliser un tour en 3 minutes 24
secondes et 8 183 millièmes soit une
différence de 4 centièmes de seconde au
tour
je vous parlais du régime que j'ai fait
tout à l'heure où je me devais de perdre
cinq kilos
keystone représente 5 kg sur une voiture
de course qui fait 930 kg pour 600
chevaux
et bien selon les ingénieurs 5 kg ça
doit nous permettre de gagner deux
dixièmes de seconde par tour sur un
circuit comme celui des 24 heures du
mans qui fait plus de 13 kilomètres et
donc comme je vous l ai dit j'ai eu
cette pole position grâce à quatre
centièmes de seconde
je vous assure je sens régime j'avais
pas cette pole position
comment vous aider à images est un petit
peu à imaginer ce que représente 4
centièmes de seconde
c'est essayer ce soir tranquillement
chez vous prenez mon prono maître de
votre smartphone tu essayé de le
déclencher et de le stopper le plus
rapidement possible en gros et c'est
faire tac tac vous l'allumez vous le
stopper j'ai peur que vous ne soyez pas
capable de le faire en cas de centièmes
de seconde j'ai essayé plusieurs fois de
mon côté et j'ai réussi une fois à le
faire en sept centièmes de secondes soit
un laps de temps quasiment deux fois
supérieur par rapport à ce qui m'a
permis d'avoir la pole position ce
qu'attend juin dernier alors je vous
garantis que ce jour là j'ai été heureux
et j'ai été fier de m'être exigé de ce
régime car une pole position aux 24
heures du mans
ça reste gravé à vie ensuite je vous ai
parlé de curiosités dont il vous dira
soyez curieux il ya un an avec deux
camarades de classe nous avons décidé de
se lancer en parallèle de nos d'études
dans une aventure entrepreneuriale à ce
moment là on n'a pas décidé
on n'a pas cherché à trouver quelque
chose de nouveau à trouver une idée qui
allait tout révolutionner non à ce
moment là on a juste été curieux de
regarder ce qui fonctionne
outre atlantique on a analysé différents
business model des start-up émergentes
aux états unis on a analysé un petit peu
leur concept et l'appétence du marché
français voire européens à ces
différents concepts puis on a décidé de
choisir une offre on développerait en
france à ce moment là on n'a rien créé
on n'a rien inventé
on a juste été curieux de regarder ce
qui fonctionne ailleurs et on a essayé
de l'emporter chez soi alors bien
évidemment c'est pas parce que quelque
chose fonctionne à l'étranger que ça
marchera forcément chez soi cependant
penser qu'on est capable de trouver une
idée à laquelle personne n'a jamais
pensé et de la développer
nous paraît un petit peu prétentieux et
surtout risque de vous faire perdre du
temps or si jamais vous retrouvez un
petit peu face à un mur face à un
problème que vous n'arrivez pas à
résoudre n'ayez pas peur d'en parler
autour de vous de demander de l'aide
renseignez vous et je suis persuadé vous
trouverai quelqu'un qu'il sera vous
aider ensuite je vous ai parlé d' audace
pourquoi je vous ai parlé d' audace
parce que à la curiosité souvent j'aime
rajouter un petit peu d'audace ça
m'arrive de dire démarrer la voiture a
accéléré et foncez on n'y allait pas les
yeux fermés bien évidemment mais foncé
car il n'y a qu'en fonçant que vous
ferez des erreurs qui vous permettront
d'être meilleur par la suite
vous parlez de cette aventure
entrepreneuriale avec mes deux collègues
ça faisait six mois qu'on avançait sur
notre projet est alors que dans toute
aventure on commence avec énormément de
motivation au fur et à mesure ont subi
des échecs un premier achat qu un
deuxième échec un troisième échec un
quatrième un cinquième échec si fait que
la motivation elle est passée du top
jusqu'au à l'endroit le plus bas et à ce
moment là on était un peu face au mur et
on a décidé de faire tapis c'est à dire
qu'on a décidé d'abattre leurs dernières
cartes
or quelle était cette dernière car cette
dernière carte
c'était d'envoyer à un mail un mail à un
grand p dg français en fait depuis le
premier jour de notre aventure
entrepreneuriale
on avait une entreprise française en
ligne de mire
ce mail ça nous a permis de lui montrer
et de lui prouver que son concurrent
numéro un
utilisée aux états unis une stratégie
qui est applicable pour lui en france on
ait eu plusieurs échanges qui nous a
permis ensuite de partir sur une
collaboration ensemble
alors je vous garantis que c'est un
petit mail ça paraît rien et pourtant ce
petit mail
il a fait que notre aventure
entrepreneuriale
elle a vraiment pris un élan positif et
on a vraiment réussi à aller de l'avant
ça a tout changé pour enfin je vous
parlais de diversification dans une ère
où tout se joue à rien n'ayez pas peur
de diversifier vos trajectoires
je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
une ère où pour faire la différence
il faut savoir prendre des risques il
faut savoir oser prendre des risques or
pour oser prendre des risques et réussir
en tout cas peut-être réussir c'est
important de le savoir se crée des
assurances on dit souvent que la
carrière d'un sportif de haut niveau
s'arrêter à tout moment sur un petit
détail sur une blessure par exemple si
vous multipliez vos parcours si vous
essayez d'entreprendre dans différents
domaines
votre vie ne dépend pas seulement d'un
échec c'est à dire que vous pouvez avoir
un échec quelque part mais réussir autre
part ça ne permettra pas tout en cause
quotidiennement on me demande comment
j'arrive à être un petit peu influent
sur les réseaux sociaux comme instagram
comment j'arrive à être étudiant et
comment j'arrive à être en même temps
pilote autonome pour moi la réponse elle
est simple être étudiant à sciences po
paris mais sur d'un avenir qui ne se
mesure pas à 0,03 j'ai alors n'ayez pas
peur de diversifier vos compétences car
pour moi ça a été vraiment un coup
d'accélérateur dans ma carrière en me
donnant un petit peu plus de sérénité en
étant plus sûr en étant plus confiants
envers moi même et donc de réussir
finalement dans l'est plusieurs projets
de gens trop connaît et enfin pour
conclure j'aimerais terminer sur un
dernier mot sur un dernier conseil
saisissez vos opportunités saisissez les
biens saisis c'est celle qu'on vous
donne prenez les à demain et surtout ne
les relâcher pas n'aurait les relâcher
pas car si jamais vous les relâcher ne
serait-ce qu'à moitié
quelqu'un d'autre arrivera l'apprendra à
votre place et vous doublera il y a deux
mois
estelle la charmante extel qui fait
partie des organisatrices de ce texte
m'a contacté par téléphone pourront
présenter un petit peu ce projet du
texte comme l a contacté une multitude
d'autres candidats à ce moment là
j'aurais pu rester derrière mon
téléphone être caché derrière ce
téléphone ça me donnait un petit peu
d'assurance site était sans doute plus
simple pour un premier contact
mais non à ce moment là j'ai décidé de
lui demander d'aller prendre un verre
pour discuter
l'un en face de l'autre de ce projet de
cette initiative
le fait de prendre un verre et d'avoir
un contact face à face nous a permis
d'avoir une relation tout de suite un
peu plus franches une relation plus
directe plus sincères qui me permettait
en fait d'augmenter mes chances de
sélection pour ce telex alors j'espère
que ce n'est pas la seule raison de ma
présence
devant ce soir mais je suis persuadé que
ça fait partie des petits détails qui
l'air de rien on fait la différence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]